hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
getting to know your bd veritar system
for rapid detection of sars cov2
i'm alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by bd for more information
about our sponsor
please visit their website at bb.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the submit button if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
david barrett
ids business and integrator gpos
and for the q a portion we will welcome
david carey
the global product manager for point of
care at bb
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the right side of your screen david
welcome sir you may now begin your
presentation
thank you alexis i appreciate that and
thank you to all of you for joining us
we're looking forward to talking to you
today about the beatty veritour system
uh and especially around the covid
testing
just to go over a very brief agenda
we're going to start out talking about
the role of antigen testing and what
sets
this testing apart from some of the
other testing methodologies that you may
have heard about we'll then go into
talking about the veritour system
for the rapid detection of sars kobe 2
or for
covin uh we'll talk about some keys
to successful testing and how to make
sure that you're getting the best result
possible out of this system we'll then
move on to talking about
batch testing and what that is what the
workflow looks like and when it's most
appropriate
for you and finally we'll wrap up
talking about some digital resources
some online
learning resources that we have
available to you
so we're going to go ahead and just jump
right in but before we even start
talking
about anagen testing i just want to make
sure that we all get you a little bit
introduced to bd uh bd is a global
company
that manufactures and distributes
products
that uh touch patient care all the way
from the collection of a specimen
through administration of medications
all the way up through reporting and
when it comes down to
coca-19 during this pandemic this little
graphic that i'm showing you here
uh shows just the the vast array
of solutions that we have for our
customers from
collecting specimens for coveted testing
to instrumentation that actually does
the testing all the way up to
medication management and iv pumps and
catheters
and drug dispensing cabinets for
patients that are hospitalized
all the way through getting the the
report
out into the the patient electronic
reporting systems
and uh making sure that these patients
are treated
properly the right way at the right time
so uh we're focusing more today on
the point of care testing as you can see
highlighted in the orange box
or referred to also as antigen testing
now before we start talking about this
antigen testing i just like to make sure
that we're clear on what this
is you've heard about a couple of
different types of tests probably
through the media you hear about
molecular testing also referred to
as pcr testing and then you hear about
the antigen testing
or rapid testing or point of care it has
multiple different names
and as we talk about what this testing
looks like and how they're different
i like to use the the example of a
patient that has
a sars kobe 2 exposure and you can see
my little graphic of a virus there
and as a patient is exposed to that
virus
that virus is going to begin to
replicate
in the patient and as more and more
virus
becomes present in the patient we refer
to that as
viral load now viral load is essential
when it comes down to what type of
testing
is going to be used and i'd like to use
the example
of a if if our patient if our body is a
great big
soccer field and the virus is
a tennis ball and if i give you a task
of going out onto a soccer field
with a bucket and saying if you fill
this bucket with tennis balls
then you will be successful and if there
are only
four or five or six tennis balls out on
that field you're going to have a hard
time
detecting those well what molecular
testing does
pcr testing does is it actually
amplifies
those tennis balls so instead of having
five or six tennis balls out there
we now have hundreds of thousands of
tennis balls and it's going to be really
easy for us to fill the bucket
so this is where pcr testing comes into
play
very early on in the infection cycle
and pcr testing since it amplifies
or gives us multiple copies of what
we're looking for
it can pick up a test or a positive
result very very early
however today we're talking about anagen
testing
and what a couple of things
differentiate antigen testing
from the pcr testing first of all pcr or
molecular testing requires
very expensive specialized equipment it
requires
a different degree of training and
expertise
it's a very complex test that does take
longer this is the one that you hear
about when people say oh i got tested
and they said that i'll have my result
back within a couple of days
that's because they're getting a pcr
test so today as we talk about anagen
testing
what anagen testing does is it looks at
the actual
number of targets the actual amount of
virus that
is in the patient at the time of the
specimen collection
so now if we go back to our tennis ball
analogy
instead of having to amplify the number
of tennis balls
we're looking for hundreds of thousands
of tennis balls that are there
because that's what the patient has has
grown up
through the replication cycle of the
virus
and that's when the the antigen test is
going to pick it up so with that
an antigen test is going to pick up or
is designed to pick up a positive
a few days after a patient or within a
few days of the patient becoming
symptomatic
and as that viral load begins to drop
off then it's going to be more likely
that a patient will be negative
now one thing we want to make sure of is
you've also heard about
antibody testing now the antibodies come
along after an infection
after the immune system has done its job
and has cleared out the virus from
our body we have these antibodies left
behind
and we are not doing antibody testing
but the verator system
we just want to make sure that everybody
is clear that today we're talking about
antigen
or looking for the presence of the virus
itself not
antibody which is the thing that is
responsible for clearing the virus
so now that we're clear on what anagen
testing
is and when it's appropriate let's go in
and get you introduced to the bd veritor
plus system
so as you look at the picture of this v
the video veritour plus i'm
i want you to think about simplicity
you'll notice on there that there's only
one button that can be used
on the entire reader and there's a very
uh very simple screen on it so even as
you look at this
it's simple and if you walk away with
one thing that you remember about the bb
veritor plus
it is simplicity so what this provides
you
as an anagen test it gives you the
ability to get
a digital readout optically or
digitally read result in 15 minutes for
sars kobe 2.
it also simplifies your testing by
giving you a very
easy streamlined workflow which we'll
talk about
all in a reader that does not have
multiple buttons
keyboards any kind of maintenance or
calibration required
everything is as simple as can be
i do also want to point out at this time
that you will hear me interchangeably
use the word
stars kobe 2 covid covet 19
we're all talking about the same virus
uh that is
responsible for the pandemic that we're
in today
so let's go ahead and get you introduced
to
the sars kobe 2 or the covet kit that
can be used
for the veritour system this kit is
designed
to detect the sars kobe 2 antigen in
nasal swabs we'll talk more about the
specimen collection
but this is a nasal collection not
a nasopharyngeal and we'll talk about
the difference between those in a moment
it is designed for use within the first
five days of symptom
onset it is designed for use
with the nasal swabs only
and it does provide you an incubation
time of 15 to 20 minutes and only about
one minute of sample prep time
and one of the great things about our
emergency use authorization from the fda
on this kit is that it can be used in
any clea
environment from high to moderately
complex
and even clia waived environments
so as you get your veritour
kit for stars kobe 2 we'll just talk
about some of the things that are in the
box
you're going to find 30 individually
wrapped test
cartridges or cassettes and you can see
a little picture of that off to the
lower right hand side of this slide
you're going to get 30 pre-filled
reagent tubes
that are going to be used for processing
the specimen we'll introduce you to
those in a minute
you're also going to get 30 nasal swabs
so these are the swabs that will be used
for your specimen collection
you'll receive a set of positive and
negative controls
and you'll receive a document that shows
where you can go
download your package insert
electronically we are not including the
package inserted paper form in these
kits
we provide you with with quick reference
cards
for collecting a sample as well as for
running a test what you do not get in
the kit
is the bd veritor plus analyzer itself
that needs to be
acquired separately uh you we do not
provide you with the gloves and any
other appropriate ppe
or a timer for the kit but just about
everything that you need with the
exception of the reader itself
is included in this kit
so we'll move on we'll talk about how a
specimen
is run and your this this graphic that
you see here is taken right from the
quick reference card
so we'll talk briefly about how to
collect a specimen
now we talked earlier and said that the
this is a nasal collection not the
nasopharyngeal the nasopharyngeal
collection are the ones that you hear
people talk about
the nightmare that they had to go
through when they went and had their
their test run and that swab went all
the way back and they felt like it was
touching their brain
that's a nasopharyngeal swap this is
only a nasal swab
so you're going up into about mid
terminate
about an inch and a half or two inches
up in the nostril
and you're going to insert that swab
into the nostril
and go around 360 degrees
all the way inside the nostril rotating
the swab
while you're collecting it and then
you're going to move over to the other
nostril with the same swab and do
the same thing that swan then can come
back to the testing site
and you will take the uh
the reagent vial that is shown there in
step two
you're going to pop off the little
yellow cap
and you're going to insert the swab all
the way into the bottom of the vial
where the liquid resides
and you're going to plunge the swab up
and down
mixing it around for about 15 seconds
and then when you remove the swab the
walls of this
tube are flexible so you can pinch those
walls together
against the shaft of the swab so that
when you pull that swab out it rings
all of the remaining fluid out of the
swab and remains
in the reagent vial at this point you
can snap down the
the little dropper cap that's on there
and you will invert that dropper
the reagent vial with the dropper cap
and dispense
three drops of solution into
the well that is marked with the little
icon that shows three drops
at this point you'll set your timer and
you will let this sample
incubate for 15 minutes
at the end of the 15 minute incubation
period you'll simply
turn on your reader your reader will go
through a quick self test
and then it will give you the
instructions for what you need
to do next and that is simply insert the
test cartridge into the side
of the reader where you can see the
cartridge there in the picture
it'll take about three seconds with a
countdown to give you a result
and then it will provide you with your
result it will say
kobe to negative or kobe 2 positive
depending on if the patient is negative
or positive
really could not be any simpler
so with that we're going to talk about
just some
steps to ensure that your testing is
as successful as possible
as a laboratory and myself i always like
to make sure that people understand that
a quality specimen will give you a
quality result
and this system the the uh the veritour
system itself as well as the kobe 2
assay have a very high degree of
accuracy
uh we actually compared 226
nasal swabs between the veritor
and a pcr that molecular method that we
talked about at the very beginning to
determine
the accuracy and what we found with our
positive percent agreement claims and
our negative percent agreement claims
is that when a when the system reports
out a positive result
you can be assured that that is truly
a positive result we show that there's
no cross-reactivity between
other human coronaviruses or flu tests
or
flu viruses or any other respiratory
viruses
however despite any of those performance
claims
uh like i said just a moment ago the the
test system is
only as good as the person collecting
the specimen and the person running the
test
so there are just a few key steps that
we want to make sure we touch on
we want to make sure that you're
following the instructions for use
specific to the sars kobe 2 test
now the veritour system is able to run
flu testing
rsv testing and group a strep testing
and if you know how to use
any of those tests that does not mean
that you know how to use the sars kobe 2
test
so we need you to follow the
instructions that are specific
to that test we also want to make sure
that we are following the instructions
very closely for specimen collection
and then making sure that we follow the
procedure steps
exactly as they are written on the quick
reference guide
now just a couple of points that that
come up that we want to make sure of
is only use the components that
come in the kit for the sars kobe test
their kobe 2 test so we want to make
sure that we're not
using any of the other reagent vials
from any other kit
if you have flu kits sitting there on
your shelf we want to make sure that
you're not using your agent files from a
fluke kit you're only using the reagent
files from
the sars kobe 2 kit we also want to make
sure that we are
only using the nasal swabs that come
with the kit you may have
other swabs dacron swabs or con cotton
tip swabs sitting around
your uh at your facility and we want to
make sure that you're not
using those only use the swabs that come
in a kit those are the approved
collection swaps for this test
we also want to make sure that you are
processing your specimens within
an hour of collection
and then one of the last items is we
want to make sure that you
are incubating for the full period of
time
15 to 20 minutes do not read before the
incubation time
and then lastly we want to make sure
that you are letting the reader
do the the reading of the test for you
it's really easy to look at the test and
think that you see a line and that you
can call it a positive or a negative but
this system is designed to be read
digitally with the veritour reader and
we want to make sure that you're letting
that reader do the work that it's
supposed to do and that we are not
reading those visually
all right so let's just talk a little
bit about batch testing and where that
comes into play
so the veritour reader actually has two
different
modes of reading there is a mode
called analyze now mode which is the one
that i just went through
with you where you'll incubate your
cartridge and then
pop it in the reader and the reader will
read the test for you and give you a
result
there's another mode called walk away
mode
now walk away mode is great for
situations
where maybe you have a lot going on that
you're taking care
of uh different patients or if you're in
a long-term care facility you're taking
care of their various needs of residents
and you cannot sit and be tied to the
reading
of the results well walk away mode
allows you to once you insert the you
inoculate the test strip with the three
drops
you can put the reader into walk away
mode it tells you how to do it right on
the display
just by pressing the button twice and
then it will instruct you to insert the
cartridge and when you do that it starts
the countdown timer at 15 minutes for
you
and then whether you're there or not it
will read the test
and it will have the result there
waiting for you when you get back to the
reader
now that system doesn't or that
methodology doesn't always work the best
in very busy facilities where they're
doing
multiple tests at a time maybe you're
you're on the kind of facility where
you're getting 5 to 10 or 15 tests at a
time and that's where batch testing
really comes into play and
batch testing allows you to set up
multiple
specimens all at the same time and read
them in a very
fast fashion now we have provided
a work card document similar to what you
see on the screen here
at bdvarator.com uh that gives you the
way to do
batch testing with up to 10 tests
and you can process all 10 tests within
26 minutes very easily and basically
what we're going to do
is each step of the process will be
taken to completion for all 10 of our
specimens
so we're going to make sure that we
collect all 10
swabs first and then when we have all 10
of our swabs
then we're going to go ahead and we're
going to process all 10 of those swabs
into 10 of our reagent files
and then once all of those reagent vials
are processed then we're going to go
sequentially
and we're going to apply three drops of
the first vial
to a reagent cartridge three drops of
the second vial to a reagent cartridge
and so on and so forth until we have
gotten
all the way through our
our reagent files and all of our
cartridges have now been inoculated
at this point we can start our timer for
15 minutes
and when that 15 minutes elapses then we
can
read the first cartridge and record the
result read the second cartridge and
record the result
in a stepwise fashion until we've gone
through all 10
cartridges now going back to steps for
success one of the things that we want
to make sure of that we're doing
is clearly labeling our swaths
and our reagent vials and our test
cartridges with whatever patient
identifier we're using
if it's patient initials if we have a
patient number
we just want to make sure that we're not
getting swabs reagent vials and
cartilages
mixed up but all of this is
made very very clear on the workflow
guide that we've provided here
and then also i'm showing you right
now a youtube link
that shows you a guide to batch testing
where
it takes all of those steps that i just
gave you
and it uh it shows you in a video
fashion
how to do those so you can um you can go
to the bd
youtube channel and look at this guide
to batch testing or you can just follow
this link
right here okay
all right so moving on we'll talk
a little bit about some of the reporting
options now one of the steps that i
gave you in the uh
in the the process of of running a test
is
once you read the test cartridge
and you have a result you record that
result
well there are a number of ways of doing
that and
we'll talk about four different methods
that are available to you
so the first one here is manual
reporting and this is probably going to
be the one that
is satisfactory for
most users where we keep a
notebook or a spreadsheet or
anything like this that has the ability
to document a patient identifier
what test is being run and then if it's
positive or negative
however some people prefer to have a
printed record
and we do have the ability through the
usb
port that is on the back of the reader
to connect to a small
thermal printer these thermal printers
are available through
most distributors they're available on
amazon.com
and when the reader gives the results
it will also give a digital printout
of what that result is whether it's a
cov2 positive cov2 negative
if you're running flu it will say flue a
positive or fluid negative blue be
positive whatever
the result may be it'll print out and
then
that printed record can be kept with
whatever kind of charting method you may
have
the third methodology we have is there
is an additional module that can be
purchased that just pops right in the
front of the veritour reader
that gives you barcode scanning
capabilities and this is referred to as
an
info scan and once you're using that
you can scan barcodes of user ids you
can scan barcodes of
patient ids you can scan the lot numbers
on a kit
just about any of the barcodes that you
may need to scan
you now have the ability to do so
and with this if you're using it with
the thermal printer
now when the result prints out you're
going to have
a user id on there you're going to have
the patient id you're going to have all
of the
items on that result
the result printout that you scanned
the other thing that this gives you the
ability to do is now
you can plug the reader in via that same
usb cable to a computer
and you can download the database via a
csv
file and import that into excel for
manipulation
as you need the last
and fourth method of reporting
automates the entire process through a
software
service that we have that's referred to
as synapsis informatics
and what this does is takes all of the
previous steps that we told you about
with the barcode scanning
and it uploads all of those results into
the synapses software
and then provides you with robust
reporting capabilities
one of the nice things about this is
that it does streamline the
hhs reporting requirements and
uh gives you a a nice record
of who's running tests what patients are
having tests run
on them what tests are being run just
about anything you can think about with
advanced
analytics and reporting and your bd
representative can provide you with more
information
on any of these solutions whether it's
the printer
or the info scan or the synapsis
informatics
uh your bd representative would be able
to provide you with information on that
okay so we're going to move on now to
talking about some digital resources
and the online learning that we have
available to you
so one of the things as a global company
that bd
really excels at is providing our
customers
with online learning platforms uh
we make sure that you have everything
available to you that you need to be
able to have
a customized training uh
curriculum or format for any of
your groups or or regardless of the size
of group
uh these resources are updated on a
regular basis so as new information
comes out or no
new tools are available the the online
resources
are updated there are a couple of main
websites
and we have them right here for you
bb.com
forward slash covet 19 is one site that
has
a wealth of information about the sars
kobe 2 testing
you can also go to bdvarator.com
and at that site you will find
a wealth of information about all of the
other things
that the beady baritor can do now on
these sites
one of the other things that you'll have
the ability to do is you can watch
videos that show you how to properly
collect a specimen
watch videos on how to properly run a
test
um any of the documents that we've
talked about
uh throughout this presentation are
available for download
on these sites as well and then we also
have the youtube channel that we talked
about earlier that
not only shows you how to do the batch
testing but
provides you with other resources as
well
for training learning about
how to run a test and allowing you
to link to those those videos uh as you
work on your training curriculum
so i provided you one of those links
right here
uh bdvarator.com or bdbaritor.bd.com
sorry that's been updated and so you can
grab
that link and uh
and use that as one of the resources
that's available to you
and then also we wanted to just talk to
you briefly about
our approach to implementation of this
system
so we work very closely with our
customers understand
exactly what their needs are because
everybody has different training needs
some people have small groups of
users some people have larger groups of
users we work with you and we develop a
customized plan that works best for you
for some people they are fine with all
of the online
online training resources for other
people they may need to have
train the trainer programs put into
place so we work with you on all of
those things
and then as a global company as well we
do provide you with
ongoing support post implementation
so we have an entire group of experts
uh that are dedicated to customer
service and customer care
so should you run into problems or
issues
along the way then you can just reach
out to us and we'll be happy to assist
you with whatever those may be
so just a couple of other links here
again that you can snag
so those education resources are at
beadyverator.bd.com and you can snag
this link right here
which has a number of the educational
resources for you
as well as this link right here which is
specific to covet 19
testing and we'll provide you with
everything that we've talked about here
today
so just as a final note there are a
couple of disclaimers that we need to
make sure that we
clarify that the sars kobe 2 test
is for use only under the emergency use
authorization by the fda uh that this
product has not been fda cleared or
approved
but is authorized by the fda under that
emergency use
authorization by authorized laboratories
that this product has been authorized
only for the detection of proteins or
those antigens from
sars cov2 not for any other viruses or
pathogens
and then lastly the product is only
authorized
for the duration of the declaration
that make the emergency use
authorization
necessary and that could be revoked
or terminated at any point in time
so with that that is the end of our
presentation
and i think alexis are we going to go
ahead and open up to
the q a portion
yes absolutely so thank you david
barrett for that
informative presentation i would also
like to now welcome
david carey to join us for the q a
portion of this webinar
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
when should i run the controls that come
in the kit
did we get david carrey on audio or
should i just take him
can you hear me oh there we go david
sorry i wasn't sure whether which one
which one of us he'd like to take that
call
um do those three we bd we provide
three um guidance uh lines for use of
the controls
um really once whenever you get a new
kit lot that comes in
um if you have a new operator that
you're bringing on board
um and really and also with it and the
third one third qualifier is if there
are any internal quality procedures or
internal quality control procedures at
your institution that requires you
to run additional controls
one other thing that i like to just
throw out there as well that
a number of my customers have done is
usually you are fine
running ace both a positive and a
negative control
if you get a shipment of boxes that are
all the same lot
so you should only have to run your
controls for one uh for one lot
and what many of my customers have done
is
uh if they have extra controls
left over they just throw those in a
drawer and those
are great to use for proficiency testing
so like david said when you're when
you're training a new user
uh you would have them use those
controls as if they were a patient
and if you just hold on to any of your
controls don't discard
uh any unused controls they're great for
those training purposes
great thank you so much to you both for
that answer um
david i believe you might have mentioned
this um earlier in the presentation but
uh one question that came up was can i
do an np swab
yeah i can i can go ahead and take that
so this is not
an np squad this is a nasal or which is
a nasopharyngeal swab
uh this is a nasal swab only and
when you when you see the size of the
swabs you would not ever even want to
attempt to do a nasopharyngeal swab the
nasopharyngeals are
very tiny and have a flexible tip and
this is a larger more rigid swab so we
want to make sure that
the we are only using the approved
specimen type
which is a nasal swab in both nostrils
great thank you so much for that
clarification moving on to
our next question is the veriter system
portable or
does it need to stay plugged into the
wall
okay there you go dude yeah i'll go
ahead and take this one i forgot to
mention it but uh yeah one of the one of
the other
very convenient points with the the
veritour plus system
is that it is portable it does have a
rechargeable battery
so it comes with a uh a power cable that
will charge the battery when it's
plugged in but if you need to take it
with you
you can just unplug it and that battery
will stay charged
uh the one thing that i will say
is that if you are running in that walk
away mode
that we talked about the system does
require itself to be plugged into
the wall into the wall charger while
you're in walk away mode because it
doesn't want to run the chance of having
that battery
run down while you're away
great thank you so much um our next
question that came
in does the same system test for the flu
strap and rfb
this one yeah you can you can use the
same the same virtual platform or
can run all the assays you would
obviously need the individual kits
for flu abs group a strap and rsv
but the same the same veritor instrument
can run all three
independently
perfect david thank you so much for that
um we do want to remind our audience you
know any questions that we don't have
time for today
and those that we aren't able to get to
will be addressed by our speakers
um via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
um so let's move on to our next question
um what do you do if more than three
drops are put in a well
or not three full drops so half falls
outside the well for an example
david i can take this one so i i think
the capacity of the well is really good
it's going to determine that so i don't
think it's possible to put more than
three in there you're going to kind of
fill it up with three
so there's not as much of a problem
except the fact that you if you oh if
you put too much sample in
then there would be a concern around not
having enough for a repeat if required
um if not three if not four three four
drops in there if you
uh for some particular reason some of it
fell out of the well
there should be res little uh extraction
reagent in the vial
for you to add an additional drop so
let's say you've got two and then mist
on one you should there should be
residual material or stretching reagent
in the vial
for you to add additional drop or soda
to to get the full amount in there
great thank you um so here here's
another one
um so just for really clarification so
the controls are swabs is that correct
that is correct in the box there will be
a
there a little foil pouch and there's
one that uh
very clearly shows that it is a positive
control swab and the other one
is very clearly marked as a negative
control swap
and they're processed just like a
regular patient squat
so it does because of that it does test
the
uh it tests the integrity of the full
system all the way from
processing of the uh of the swab in the
reagent vial
uh all the way through the reading and
reporting out of a result
great thank you so much david for for
that clarification
um we do want to thank you again david
barrett and david carey
um do you have any final comments for
our audience um
david barrett i'll go ahead and start
with you
yeah the only final comment that i would
have is that uh bd
is here for you and
is available to help with any of the
questions that you may have
we do have a team of experts that
is that r1 800 number that is available
to
answer any additional questions and
as alexis said any questions that we
didn't get to today
uh will be sent the answers will be sent
out
later after this call
and for me just thank everyone for
attending today uh and as well
if if there's any more information you
want to know about the beady veritour
um we're constantly updating our web
page the the microsite that's dedicated
to veritable bdvarito.com
um so there'll be new content loaded
there on a pretty regular basis so if
there's anything
um that you didn't see on the webinar
today i'm sure there's
extra material you can find on on that
website as well
thank you so much to to you both before
we go i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
again like we mentioned
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration so please feel free to keep
those questions coming in
we would like to once again thank david
barrett for his presentation
and david carey for joining us for that
q a portion
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor bb
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now stay safe stay
healthy everyone
and we'll see you next time bye